Welcome to the Man
of Recaps, this is Echo.
In the Hawkeye show, we met villain Maya Lopez,
who was a top boss in the criminal organization
of Wilson Fisk, yes, Kingpin!
Maya is a deaf Native American girl
who had a happy family
until her mom died in a car accident
where she lost her leg.
She and her dad moved to New York,
where he's a good guy,
but a criminal working for Kingpin.
And Fisk himself took an interest in young
Maya, became her mentor and “uncle.”
One day Hawkeye, in his “Ronin” faze,
attacked and killed her father, no!
But this brought her even
closer to her uncle Kingpin,
who made her an enforcer
because she's a top tier fighter.
But she's not as good as--
oh, who's that?!
Yes, it's Daredevil!
They have an awesome fight, hyah!
Oh, it's good to see him in action again!
But unfortunately, he's not in this show,
he just came in for this one scene.
And now catching up
to the events of Hawkeye, he told Maya
it was actually Fisk
who told him to kill her dad!
So she confronted her Uncle Wilson,
and shot him in the face.
But Kingpin is a tough guy to kill,
he survived a bullet to the brain.
So now Maya is on the
run from Kingpin's gang.
She goes back to her hometown in Oklahoma
and has homecoming shenanigans
like meeting up with her cousin Biscuits.
Her cousin Bonnie
she was real close with as a kid,
but she doesn't even tell her she's back,
to just let Bonnie live a normal life.
She goes to the roller skating rink
where her Uncle Henry works.
But Henry also works for Fisk in shipping.
Maya wants his help to take over
and become the “Queen-pin,”
but Henry doesn't want to
bring trouble to their town.
So Maya goes alone
for an epic train heist!
Well almost alone, her
cousin Biscuits picks her up.
But she didn't steal anything,
she planted a bomb!
Boom! Blows up Fisk’s weapons warehouse!
Now this random guy from the roller
rink captures Maya to collect her bounty.
Bonnie happened to come by too, so
they're both captured, cousins reunited.
A goofy British gangster
comes to collect her,
but Maya is real resourceful, makes
a gun out of a roller blade
and manages to escape! Has an epic fight,
throws ski balls at these dudes!
But in the end they're about to kill her,
when they get the call to let her go...
Because Kingpin himself
has traveled to Oklahoma
to see his wayward niece in person.
And he's not here to kill her,
he just wants to talk.
We get more of their backstory,
of how he was protective of young Maya,
beat this guy to death
because he wouldn't sell her ice cream.
And he's like, “Look, sorry
about your dad, that was just business.”
“You shot me in the face,
I think we're even now.”
“But, Maya, I really think of you as my family,”
“I want you to come back and work
for me”
“and be the heir to my criminal empire.”
Maya's conflicted, but Fisk is
a really persuasive guy
who's good at manipulating
impressionable young minds.
He pulls out his go-to move
and tells a story, “When I was a boy...”
He gives her the hammer
he killed his father with,
but she doesn't kill him,
so maybe these two can be family again.
But, meanwhile, Maya has been reconnecting
with her real family.
And she's been having weird visions
of her ancestors,
It's like “Yo Grandma, what's going on?”
And her grandma tells her
how they're all connected,
and her own mom
in fact, had healing powers.
So Maya has a good long think
about who her real family is,
and she decides to bail on Fisk.
But Fisk does not take rejection well,
he kidnaps her grandma.
So Maya puts on the new
prosthetic leg her grandpa built,
and the Choctaw inspired super
suit her grandma sewed.
So it comes down to the grand finale
at the Powwow Party,
where she confronts
Fisk to save her family.
Of course, she walked
directly into a trap,
but now the powers of her ancestors
“echo” down through the ages to her!
And yeah, it's not metaphorical,
she gets superpowers, all right!
Outside, the British gangster
is going to blow up the powwow,
but luckily her Uncle Henry
is there to stop it.
And also Cousin Biscuits
rolls up in a monster truck
to take out the rest of Fisk's goons!
So now Echo grabs her Uncle Fisk
and uses her powers to get in his mind.
But she doesn't want to kill him,
he really is like family too,
so she tries to heal him of his own
childhood traumas.
It doesn't really seem like it worked,
but Fisk does leave her alone for now.
On his flight back to New York,
the news reminds him
that the mayoral election is coming up,
and now it seems like he's going to run.
As for Maya Lopez, she's
reconnected with her family,
decided to leave her life of crime
behind, and be a hero now, “Echo.”
And that's where Echo comes to an end.
If you like this recap hit that subscribe button
for more of the best
recaps of TV and movies.